وصفه هذه الاجواء قالت وكاله توريا نوفلز
الروسيه ان ميليشيا فاجنر سيطرت على مواقع
جديده وصفتها بالمهمه داخل المنطقه
الصناعيه وسط مدينه باخموت واضفت الوكاله
نقلا عن مصدر الموالي لروسيا في اقليم
دومباس ان وحدات فاجنر سيطرت على مواقع
داخل مصنع معالجه الصلب على الضفه الغربيه
لنهر بخمودكا ما يسهل السيطره على المنطقه
الصناعيه ويجعلها منطلقا لهجمات
على ما تبقى من احياء يسيطر عليها الجيش
الاوكراني
في الاثناء نشر المركز الاعلامي العسكري
لوزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه بيانا يشرح فيه
اهميه الدفاع عن بخموت معتبرا ان القوات
الروسيه تركز عملياتها على منطقه دونيتسك
بهدف الوصول الى الحدود الاداريه لمنطقتي
دونيتسك
وزياده كثافه العمليات الهجوميه في
اتجاهات ليمان ومارينكا واشار البيان الى
ان الدفاع عن باخموت يساهم في ربط القوات
الرئيسيه والاحتياطيات الكبيره للروس في
مكان واحد وتكبيدها خسائر كبيره واجبار
القوات الروسيه على اجراء عمليات التناوب
متكرره للوحدات المشاركه في العمليات
الهجوميه ما يساهم في اضاعه الوقت
والموارد وافقادهم امكاناتهم الهجوميه
وقدراتهم في اتجاهات اخرى وفق ما جاء في
البيان
مرحبا بكما حسان ابداء معك واطلعنا على
اخر التطورات
نعم سلمى التطورات
متزامنه هناك عند جبهه بخمه حيث يؤكد قائد
القوات البريه الجنرال اولي في زيارته
الجديده للجبهه الشرقيه وفق ما اعلنت
قياده القوات البريه ان الاوضاع هنا ما
زالت صعبه وان القتال
يعتبر قتالا في معركه شرسه بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه يؤكد ان
القوات الروسيه ما زالت تحاول التوجه نحو
وسط المدينه من اتجاهات مختلفه وان القوات
الاوكرانيه تصد هذه الهجمات بشكل متواصل
وتكبد القوات الروسيه التي تحاول الهجوم
خسائر كبيره هذه التصريحات تاتي في سياق
سلسله من التصريحات من عدد من المسؤولين
من بينهم كذلك الرئيس الاوكراني الذي يؤكد
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تكبد القوات الروسيه
مهاجمه في منطقه باكموت
بخسائر كبيره تحدث عن رقم خلال الاسبوع
الماضيه فوق الالف ومئه قتيل و1500 مصاب
من القوات المهاجمه في محور باخموت وشكر
الجنود الذين ما زالوا عند هذه الجبهه هذا
يشير الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه تريد ان
تواصل القتال هناك وان تدافع عما تبقى من
هذه المنطقه منطقه باخموت وفي ذات الوقت
فاننا نرصد كثافه في القصف الاوكراني
باتجاه مواقع القوات الروسيه بالتزامن مع
القصف الروسي في محاوله للتقدم ليس فقط
عند الجبهه الشرقيه في منطقه انما ايضا
باتجاه المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه حيث كانت
تحاول القوات الروسيه التوجه نحو الطريق
الواصل بين هذه المناطق منطقه
اكراماتورسكوفكا وكذلك منطقه
والطريق ايضا الرئيسي الذي يؤدي من
قسطنطينه الى منطقه هذا ياتي بالتوازي مع
قيام القوات الروسيه بقصف العمق ايضا في
المناطق الغربيه لمنطقه بخموت فجر هذا
اليوم تعرضت هذه المدينه من مدينه
كراماتورسك لضربه صاروخيه حتى هذه لحظه لم
تعلن القوات او السلطات الاوكرانيه عن
معلومات دقيقه حول مكان هذه الضربه لكنها
اعلنت عن ضربه كانت قبل
في خلال اليوم الماضي وهو يلي منطقه
ومنشاه حيويه
للبنيه التحتيه تحديدا كانت احداها منطقه
سكه الحديد وتعرضت هذه ايضا لضربه صاروخيه
السلطات الاوكرانيه افصحت عن ثلاث ضربات
صاروخيه في منطقه
هذه التطورات هنا عند الجبهه الواقعه غربي
ضخمه تاتي ايضا بالتزامن مع محاولات
للتقدم للقوات الروسيه تفصح عنها القوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه
جنوب المنطقه التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه وكذلك في المحاور
الشماليه لهذه المقاطعه في منطقه
سوليدار وكذلك منطقه ليمن بالاضافه الى
محاوله للتقدم تقول القوات الاوكرانيه
انها تتصدى لها عند محور
الشرقيه مقاطعه
عند الحدود مع مقاطعته
الجانب الروسي من بيانات عن سير العمليات
العسكريه وخاصه ما يجري في بخموت
نعم عبد القادر بالفعل رئيس شركه او مالك
شركه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه التي تقود
قواته بالدرجه الاولى المعارك على الارض
في مدينه باق متاكده على ان قواته تستمر
في التقدم نحو قلب المدينه مركز المدينه
وكل ما اقتربت اكثر واكثر من وسط المدينه
كلما ازدادت المعارك ضراوه حسب تعبيره
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بحسب بريكوجن
تحاول الحفاظ على كل متر مربع من الاراضي
تقوم بارسال التعزيزات لهذه المنطقه
للحلوله دون السيطره على مركز المدينه
ولكن بحسب تصريحات ريجوجل الامور تتجه نحو
تحقيق النصر واتمام السيطره على مدينه
باخد هذا يتزامن مع اعلان مصادر عسكريه
مطلعه على ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه
احدثت فجوه في دفاعات القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في المناطق الشماليه الغربيه
من مدينه وبالتالي باتت تسيطر على الاكبر
من منطقه الاخوه فضلا عن ذلك بحسب تصريحات
هذه المصادر هناك تقدم للقوات المسلحه
الروسيه في الاطراف الغربيه من مدينه
باخموت اقتحمت اخر يعني المواقف المواقع
الدفاعيه للقوات الاوكرانيه في هذه
المنطقه قربه
قرب المنطقه الغربيه للمدينه قرب المقبره
في هذا الجزء من مدينه باخ من فضلا عن ذلك
هناك تنبؤات ووفقا للعديد من المراقبين
والمحللين العسكريين التي تتحدث عن انه في
حال لم تتلقى القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
في القريب العاجل الامر بترك ومغادره
مدينه اباخ متعبره عبر طريق سفيان فهذا
يعني ان مدينه باخت ستواجه نفس مصير مدينه
مريول سيتم يعني اتمام احكام تطويق هذه
المدينه وبالتالي القضاء على كل من يتبقى
من القوات الاوكرانيه في الداخل وعليه فن
الاوضاع في غايه الصعوبه بالنسبه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه هذه المصادر تتحدث عن
ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه القوات الجويه
اباتت تستخدم قنابل موجهه
تزن نحو ونصف الطن وهذه القنابل في ظل
استخدام هذه القنابل فان اي مقاومه حسب
تعبيرها ستكون عديمه الفائده
فيما يتعلق جهه اخرى المعارك مستمره في
مختلف الجبهات بالدرجه الاولى في محور
كوبايات محور كراسنا لمان محور على سبيل
المثال في دنيس خلال الساعات الاربعه
والعشرين الماضيه قامت القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه باستهداف يعني ثلاثه احياء
سكنيه هناك اصابات في صفوف المدنيين فضلا
عن ذلك هناك معارك ضاريه ايضا تجري في
محور دانياسك الجنوبيه وايضا في محور
زوباروجيا ووفقا لتصريحات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه فان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
تكبدت خسائر تقدر بنحو 400 عسكري اوكرانيا
خلال اليوم الماضي في مختلف الجبهات شكرا